c'est ici dans cette toute nouvelle
écurie 5 étoiles que le club hippique de
Versailles va accueillir l'équipe
d'équitation de Suède pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 2024 à 10 minutes en
voiture du château de Versailles lieu
des épreuves de sport équestre ce nouvel
espace comprend 8 nouveaux box de plus
de 10 mètres carrés un solarium ainsi
que tout le confort nécessaire pour les
chevaux et les cavaliers alors une
fierté et puis surtout un achèvement
c'est vrai que ça a été beaucoup de
travail pour en être là où on en est
aujourd'hui donc c'est une fierté et en
même temps un réel soulagement pour les
équipes je me suis battue comme une
lionne pour que l'équitation ait lieu à
Versailles parce qu'il y a eu un moment
l'envie de ramener l'équitation à la
mode Beuvron dans le Loir-et-Cher là où
est le siège de la fédération française
j'ai voulu que l'équitation élu à
Versailles parce que l'équitation à
Versailles ça va être waouh on verra le
château en arrière fond de toutes les
épreuves mais je voulais aussi qu'il y
ait un héritage un héritage pour les
Versaillais dans ce club de
Porchefontaine son fils à monter petit
c'est un club familial qui a été par le
passé le club de référence avec des
équipements qui étaient ultra modernes
et qui avait vraiment besoin d'un
sérieux relooking et pour se relooking
le club hippique de Versailles a fait
réaménager sa carrière un nouvel
équipement que le cavalier yvelinois
médaillé de bronze aux Jeux Olympiques
de Tokyo a pu tester avec son cheval
totem de blessé et ben je trouve que
cette carrière est très bien c'est vrai
qu'elle est très homogène partout il y a
pas de différence de de de sol la
carrières subirigé maintenant c'est
vraiment la pointe de la technologie
c'est déjà c'est bien pour les chevaux
parce qu'on a une homogénéité partout et
deuxièmement au niveau de l'économie
d'eau c'est quand même assez flagrant
avec l'aide financière de la Ville de
Versailles du département des Yvelines
et de la région Île-de-France le club a
également pu construire un manège
olympique couvert un restaurant et un
espace de réunion des conditions idéales
pour l'équipe de Suède qui a récemment
les championnats d'Europe de saut
d'obstacles toutes les équipes étaient
les bienvenues il y avait pas de
sélection en termes de titres ou quoi
que ce soit le fait que ce soit la Suède
ben c'est génial parce que voilà
effectivement c'est une nation majeure
en termes d'équitation c'est chouette
qui ne rêverait pas effectivement en
football d'accueillir l'équipe du Brésil
l'équipe d'Allemagne même l'équipe de
France voilà donc non finalement on est
content ces nouveaux équipements
resteront après les Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 les adhérents du club
hippique de Versailles pourront les
utiliser ce dernier compte 1017
licenciés et une centaine de chevaux